as much as I love New York City at
Christmas time cuz I really do um I also
look forward to spending time like even
more so at my Ranch of Montana I love it
so much it's just so beautiful and look
I grew up with nothing and I finally got
something that is so magical and it's
awesome and it's beautiful and that's
why I'm really excited about the new
Montana collection by Kelly Clarkson
home exclusively at
Wayfair I was so inspired by my pan I
wanted to create something that I love
how I decorate there it's a reflection
of My Sanctuary with ranch inspired
looks and heirloom appe peal plus these
pieces are affordable which is super
cool and designed for real life to
enhance any space in your home uh today
we actually have another Montana lover
which I'm very excited about in the
house she is up in our Wayfair VIP
lounge which just got some new furniture
and decor from the Montana collection
everybody say hello to the host of the
mountain Kitchen on Magnolia Network
Andy star give it
up oh my God I love that you know all my
love of Montana Hi Neighbor what's up I
love it there it's beautiful me too yeah
do you just love you're getting to work
there now too right I am I'm so lucky
and my whole family uh my mom's side is
there so you know we all went rogue it
was great you know why because it's so
beautiful I feel like it's like the last
unchartered place it's it's so beautiful
but so you have a new show it's called
the mountain kitchen right I do what do
you cook are you really good at cooking
I well you know I don't mean to brag um
okay do you like friends to come up over
and and test your food because I don't
cook but I love eating I do I have I
have friends I have my husband you know
um yeah I you know I'm a big grandmother
basically you come in my house I need to
feed you something oh my God I'm like
that stove top kid commercial you know
that just shows up at your door right at
dinner time oh that's
weird oh you're eating okay sure I'll
come in yeah yeah I love it do you love
your new show I love it it's so great
and you know it's s it's kind of a love
letter to Montana you know Love Letter
to Boseman and all I mean it's one thing
to live there I think people don't real
like oh my God is that where you live
yeah and I love cooking with fire I
always smell like smoke honestly which
some people don't like I kind of I
always smell like smoke because we have
a fire going constantly I'm not cooking
I I love that you do um thank you Annie
for joining
us all right y'all you can catch the
mountain Kitchen on Magnolia network
with new episodes every Sunday and
streaming the same day on Max and
Discovery plus I mean hell you just want
to tune and just for the aesthetic that
place is gorgeous um and also remember
to check out the Montana collection
exclusively at Wayfair cuz I love
Montana so I was
[Music]
[Applause]
inspired thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home